prime minister boris johnson's
undergrowing pressure after two of his
most senior members of two of the most
senior members of his cabinet resigned
finance minister rishi sunak has gone
saying the public expects government to
be conducted properly competently and
seriously health minister sajud javit
has also quit concluding that he can no
longer serve mr johnson's government in
good conscience boris johnson has faced
a series of scandals over parties held
as his official residence during the
national coving 19 lockdown his most
recent troubles concerned whether he
knowingly appointed an mp chris pincher
to a senior party position despite
allegations of sexual misconduct
well mr johnson now admits that that was
an error of judgment
yes i think it was a mistake and i
apologize for
uh
for it i think in in hindsight it was
the wrong thing to do i apologize to
everybody who's been badly affected by
it
let's get more on this from quentin
peele in london he's an analyst with the
think tank at chatham house uh welcome
back to dw quentin how much trouble is
boris johnson in
a great deal these two men who've
resigned
arguably the two most serious members of
his cabinet um a string of others have
said they're not going but uh rishi
sunak and sajid javid are real
heavyweights in a government of
lightweights so i think that boris
johnson's days are increasingly looking
numbered he may stagger on for a little
while longer but i'd be very surprised
if he survives beyond the autumn
what is it about
is it these resignations or this issue
that make you so clear that he that he
will go because he has been through a
lot where in normal times uh other prime
ministers would have gone a long time
ago
yes you're absolutely right it is the it
is the issue of trust it is not this
particular issue nor indeed these
ministers going although at the heart of
the reason for their resignations is
that they see that johnson is no longer
regarded as a trustworthy figure either
out in the country but also
among his own colleagues and among his
own ministers he constantly asks them to
go out and defend him and then has to
change the story because he's invented
the circumstances so that's exactly
what's happened here and i think that
the problem for this government and for
johnson is it's no longer about policies
it's about johnson he is now the issue
he has said numerous times that he will
not resign can he be forced out of
office
well um he only survived the vote of
confidence in him
recently when 148 members of his
backbenchers in parliament voted against
him it was
on the face of it a very narrow survival
it wasn't an easy one they're not
supposed to vote for another year now uh
again but i think they'll change the
rules i think they'll have a new vote
and i think his party will in fact
effectively vote him out of office the
problem is there's no obvious successor
but rishi sunak and sajid javid the two
gentlemen who've just resigned are both
talked of as potential successors
thank you so much for that clear
analysis quentin peel from chatham house
in london
thank you
you